country music legend charlie pride
passed away at the age of 86 after
playing professional baseball he broke
into country music in the 1960s
and paved the way for black artists in
the genre
he was one of the first black singers to
perform at the grand ole opry
everyone in country music was inspired
by charlie pride
yeah and he was just honored with the
lifetime achievement award at the cma
awards
on november 11th it was a couple weeks
later that he started showing symptoms
of kova 19
and while he fought hard he succumbed to
the virus on saturday
it has led some to question whether he
contracted it
at the award show no
yeah mayor morris wrote in a since
deleted tweet
i don't want to jump to conclusions
because no family statement has been
made
but if this was a result of the cmas
being indoors we should all be outraged
rest in power charlie and mickey guyton
tweeted we never
uh we need answers as to how charlie
pride got covered
uh circumstances aside artists are also
honoring him for his incredible career
as dolly parton wrote i'm so heartbroken
that one of my dearest and oldest
friends charlie pride has passed away
it's even worse to know that he passed
away from cover 19 or a horrible
horrible virus charlie
we will always love you and the chick
said we're sad
to hear about the loss of the legendary
charlie pride who's a true gentleman
with a kind heart
our thoughts are with his loved ones his
music has made a huge
impact on the three of us and on the
world
yes at the cma awards last month charlie
performed alongside jimmy allen
hears them backstage and jimmy's tribute
to charlie he posted yesterday
and i quote i've met this guy this is a
you talk about sharp this is a child but
i wouldn't
when i was his age i wasn't that sharp
yeah i stole it from you
i tell you something he said to me he
said charlie these songs we are
recording right now 50 years from now
can be able to play them and they'll
love them just as much as they are
and i think i looked at him in 50 years
to be able to present him with the ward
and stand here next to him
and have a song with him uh it's you
imagine
one of the biggest dreams you have in
accomplishing that and that happened for
me tonight so it's just a privilege to
you know be with the guy that you know
was you know so important
in my life and making me feel
comfortable in chasing this
country music dream knowing that you
know what there's somebody that looks
like me
that did it and sold over 70 million
records you know i just want to sell 30
records and i'll be good
let's do my talking from from now
i hope through this
people that didn't know about charlie
pride or who he was and what he did i
hope they get to know him
you know through his music you know
through
his life um
he knows everything he accomplished you
know from baseball to music and just
inspiring so many people
and just having the courage to continue
to stand up and chase down the dream you
want no matter how society
might feel about what you're doing
because of color your skin
and there's just so many life lessons
that you can take from his life and
apply
you know to your own and i just you know
i
i just hope we we learn that
you know there's nothing that you can't
do you know um because he showed us that
we can
um so we definitely lost the legend man
you know for me
it feels like superman died
but he lived a good life man and he
inspired
so many people but
charlie love you we miss you
uh thanks for everything you've done
yeah lots of people are saying rest in
peace francis says he was a trailblazer
so some people are talking about the cma
thing uh bibi says
c-mages did not take covet seriously uh
no one was
wearing uh masks reena says these people
are murderers when they allow people to
ignore
a covered rule so cma has come up with a
statement saying
uh charlie was tested before he came to
the awards show
uh they followed all the protocols while
he was there and for everyone else
he tested uh negative after he left
several days after he left so
they're implying they did not get at the
cma awards but it must have been shortly
after that but
yeah either way i mean there's a lot to
the discussion about keisha what are
your initial
thoughts with charlie oh my goodness
just another legend another hero
gone i mean he really broke barriers
it was tough to you know see jimmy
struggle to talk about him that made me
really sad because i know
that charlie meant a lot to him and a
lot of his career and
comes from what charlie did and the
doors that he opened so
you know that was hard to watch but
charlie pride leaving
you know i don't care how old he was um
he still had more life to live you saw
how vibrant he was at the awards
um i'm glad that he had a wonderful life
i'm glad that he was celebrated i'm glad
that the next generation
gave him his flowers while he was alive
but
it's still gone too soon and gone in my
opinion tragically covet is a
is is horrible and terrifying and i'm
praying that it wasn't from the dmas
um i hope that everybody that was at the
cmas
are you know asking questions and have
been tested and are following the rules
because
yeah this is not we don't want this no
one wants to die from this this is crazy
um but yeah charlie was charlie was
truly incredible
and he will live on forever he did
something
he did something special you know so
it's a tough one
yeah yeah to see
black excellence at the cmas first and
foremost was just
incredible and to see the future
honoring the past
and still the present also was some
powerful moment to see but
i understand that you know with
everything going on with kova that we
want to kind of return to some sense of
normalcy i understand that
but for the cmas to have allowed people
to come
indoors without mask is careless and i
think that
when you're hosting such a massive
platform that you still
need to take those those measures so
that we as the public
could also follow suit and say okay you
know what the cma is taking this
seriously
so should we so if he did contract covet
from the cmas
wow this man has probably gone through
everything
especially as a black man he must have
gone through so
much but again like keisha said to see
that he was handed his flowers and to be
celebrated and honored
before his passing at least that is some
peace that his family could see
that he was is celebrated we got to clap
for him we got to acknowledge everything
that he's done
and hopefully that his legacy continues
to live on after this
yeah the timeline is definitely
questionable of when you would have
gotten covet like when we've gotten
after if
you know the timeline works out and i
want to bring up something that i
believe
it was kerry washington a few months ago
and i'm going to paraphrase here i'm not
going to get it right
but she talked about the idea of how
many black
heroes were losing this year and the
idea that maybe it's the idea that
you know we need to stop looking at the
heroes and start doing stuff for
ourselves who can't be looking through
these people anymore
and i'm paraphrasing a little bit i'm
not saying it correctly yeah keisha what
do you think like i mean just
in 2020 think about kobe you think about
chadwick with john lewis now you have
charlie pry like you mean
it's just been a huge year of loss for
these huge icons
we've lost a lot i mean 2028 plain fair
i tell you that
you know i feel like in a lot of ways
2020 is 20 20 vision
um it's an opportunity for us to
acknowledge that a lot of the things
that we were obsessing over
before this moment didn't matter it does
not matter
for me 2020 has been an awakening
realizing some of the things that maybe
i cared about
has no value now the only thing that
truly matters is
our health our happiness our family
humanity human rights these are the
things that we care about and we lost
people that taught us great lessons
lessons i'm praying charlie pride isn't
going to be a huge lesson for the cma
awards i'm praying that's not the case
because that would be very upsetting
especially because these award shows any
tv production in general
you assume that they are going to be at
the highest level
of coveted protocols you feel almost
safe maybe too safe you assume that
there's so many people and so many minds
behind this
um that it's going to be done well so
i'm praying that's not the case but
yeah we lost a lot of great ones this
year yeah it was a tough one yeah
without a loss losses here
we lost humans in 2020 and i think
you know we could look at these greats
and go oh my gosh they are legends they
are heroes they are celebrities but at
the end of the day they are human
and what they are showing us it doesn't
matter how much money you have
what your reputation is covid will come
for whoever it needs to come for
um and in the other situations it is
heartbreaking to see some of our
favorite people pass way too soon but
like keisha said again 2020 is also
teaching us to honor things that maybe
we were taking for granted
whether it's spending more time with our
family whether it's spending more time
with ourselves
you know being in isolation allows for
room for growth so
it's taking those moments and realizing
yes one could say oh 2020 is a dumpster
fire
and i really wish people would stop
saying that because there is still good
there is still things that we can do to
to celebrate and finish off the year on
a strong note but again
lots of lessons for us to take into 2021